the current head of shin feiner the
leader of the opposition in the Irish
Parliament Dublin is taken to pay homage
to Sean Russell a Nazi and former Ira
leader in the 1940s who died on a German
Europe for once the use of the term Nazi
in 2023 is not hyperbole the current
head of shin Fein Mary Lou McDonald is
taken to pay homage at the Statue of a
murderer who was a Nazi who was leading
a bombing campaign against British
cities as the luftwaffe was bombing
those same British cities
and Mary Lou McDonald has to pay homage
why is it what is it about this movement
that means that you still have to pay
homage to Nazis and terrorists and
killers and bombers if you are to rise
in the ranks of the movement does nobody
see the problem here